[تصفيق]
تتطور الاحتجاجات في انحاء ايران بوتيره
متسارعه لكن الانظار الان تتجه نحو
الملتقى الغربيه محافظه كردستان
اشتعالت الامور بشكل سريع في هذه المحافظه
وتصعيد قوات النظام حملاته الامنيه
العنيفه فيها
منظمه هنغاو لحقوق الانسان مقرها كردستان
العراق اشارت الى ان اكثر من 80 متظاهرا
قتلوا وتقل 4000 اخرون في المناطق ذات
الاغلبيه الكرديه وحدها
تحدثت منظمه حقوق الانسان في ايران التي
تتخذ منظومه قرر لها في اخر حصيله اصدرتها
عن مصر 72 شخصا الاسبوع الماضي وحده
56 في مناطق يقتلها الاكراد بالغرب وثقت
لجنه متابعه معتقلين في ايران شل النظام
الايراني حمله اعتقالات واسعه في مدن
مهابات
الكرديه ومدينه ايران شهر في بلوشستان
ووسط تقارير تفيد بقمع وانتهاكات جسيمه
يقوم بها النظام الايراني ضد المعتقلين في
سجونه والثقافه المفوضيه حقوق الانسان
اعتقال الالاف الانضمامهم الى الاحتجاجات
السلميه ندعو ايران لاطلاق سراح المعتقلين
واسقاط التهامي الموجهه اليهم ونطالبها
بتعليق فوري لعقوبه الاعدام
الايرانيه
من التعذيب والاعدام وحتى الاغتصاب فقط
الامن داخل السجون الى تصوير بعض مشاهد
العنف الجنسي لاستخدامها اداه الابتزاز
المتظاهرين
والمطالبه بمحاسبه المسؤول الى ان النظام
الايرانيون بدايه من الغد تمديدا بقمع قوه
الامن المحتجين في المدن الكرديه